before we move on to big numbers try
multiplying 61 with 64 we have seen
examples like 98 times 97 where both
numbers were below the base 102 times
103 where both numbers were above the
base and 1,003 times 998 where one was
above and the other below the base but
in all cases the base was a power of 10
like 10 100 1000 and so on but here the
numbers are not close to any power of 10
both numbers are close to 60 and 60 is a
multiple of 10 10 times 6 is equal to 60
that's what we mean by a multiple of
power of 10 if we had to solve something
like 701 times 703 then the base would
be 700 10 squared multiplied by 7 a
multiple of power of 10 we will look at
problems with bigger number a bit later
for now let's focus on this one the
technique we will use to solve such
problems is almost similar to the
previous one of finding the base the
deviations the sum and the product just
one little difference we will see that
soon the first step of choosing the base
was the same the second step of finding
the deviation is also the same we find
the deviations of the numbers from the
base which is 60 the deviation here will
be 61 minus 61 and the deviation here
will be 64 minus 64 the next two steps
are also the same sum on the left and
the product on the right the sum can be
any of the two diagonal numbers 60 1
plus 4 or 64 plus 1 both give us 65 and
on the right we have the product of the
deviations one multiplied by four and
that equals four as there is just one
zero in the base we will have one digit
on the right we write a four here is 650
for our answer nope
so when an additional step comes in we
have to multiply the number on the left
with this multiplying factor here it's 6
so we multiply 65 with 6 and 65 times 6
gives us 390 and we get the 4 down
that's our answer
61 times 64 is 3904 there was just one
additional step here multiplying the
number on the left with a multiplying
factor so find the base find the
deviations find the sum find the product
and then multiply the left-hand figure
with a multiplying factor let's quickly
try out another problem say we have to
multiply 371 with 399 try it out we can
see that both numbers are pretty close
to 400 if 400 is the base then 100 is
the power of 10 we are looking at 10
squared and 100 times 4 is equal to 400
371 minus 400 is equal to minus twenty
nine and 399 minus 400 is equal to -1
based our deviations done some on the
left and the product on the right 371
minus 1 is equal to 370 and on the right
we will have minus 29 x minus 1 that
will be 29 as we have two zeros in the
base we need to have two digits on the
right so we write a 29 here this is not
our answer don't forget to multiply the
number on the left hand side with 4 we
multiply 370 with 4 and that equals 1480
and we get 29 down that's the correct
answer
371 times 399 is equal to 148 thousand
29 these were the exact
when the base is a multiple of power of
10 here it was a multiple of 10 squared
or 100 the only additional step here was
to multiply the number on the left hand
side with a multiplying factor we will
look at a couple of more examples in the
next part of the session